don't sleep eating a banana okay I'm not
asleep my mind is alive okay Taylor
Swift is giving us life in this video
her mom recorded after she had LASIK eye
surgery it all went down on Thursdays
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon
Taylor opened up about recently having
LASIK eye surgery and to her surprise
her mom Andrea hilariously videotaped
the aftermath and gave the footage to
Jimmy to share so the video starts in
Taylor's kitchen when she's on the hunt
for something to eat
she found a snack stop you can't cry
after picking off the wrong banana
Taylor and her mom go into
problem-solving mode the pop superstar
was clearly stunt tee swizzles to night
show appearance comes just days before
she's set to perform on Saturday Night
Live it's gonna be mental innit like a
Randy hen dude did you write this yes
honey stupid isn't it SNL is Taylor's
latest big gig since releasing her
seventh studio album lover fans aren't
the only lover stands celebs are also
totally obsessed like Hannah Brown who
performed to the title track on Dancing
with the Stars
[Music]
well Taylor saw Hannah's Viennese Waltz
and posted about it on Instagram that
was so incredible I was so excited I
freaked out he texted me and was like
Taylor stuff just posted our video it
was on her birthday - this is a great
birthday present
[Music]